[Music]
honorable the chief justice
and the associate justices of the
supreme court of the united states
oh yeah oh yeah
all persons having business before the
honorable the supreme court of the
united states are admonished to draw
near and give their attention
for the court is now sitting
god save the united states and this
honorable court
this is america and the courts c-span's
weekly look at the federal judiciary in
this edition the audio from a
re-argument of the supreme court case
roe vs wade
this week marked the 25th anniversary of
the supreme court's decision in this
case which struck down a texas law
prohibiting abortion
this one-hour oral argument took place
october 11 1972
it was first argued on december 13 1971
here's a brief introduction to the case
by susan lowe block a professor of law
at georgetown university law center
professor susan lowe block a professor
of constitutional law and the u.s
supreme court at georgetown university
in the case of roe v wade who were the
players
well the plaintiff was jane roe
which was a pseudonym for a woman who
was pregnant who wanted an abortion
she lived in texas and under texas law
one can only get an abortion if you can
show that your life is in danger
uh jane rose life was not in danger so
she was not allowed to get an abortion
she then sued
claiming that the texas law was
unconstitutional and she sued the
attorney general of texas wade who
defended the law and until this case
went before the court the laws in the
country were dictated by the states
they were and they still are um but
what this case was saying is that the
constitution you know
uh
demands that states do certain things
and forbids them from doing other things
so that you had this sort of situation
where some states like texas were very
restrictive
no abortion unless the life of the
mother is in danger
some states allowed abortions but only
if the life or health of the mother was
in danger
other states like new york had
liberalized their laws so that
it was quite easy to get an abortion
so what happened if you were in texas
for example or any state with a very
restrictive law
and wanted an abortion you would if you
had the money could go to something like
new york and get an abortion but someone
like jane rowe who was had had very
little money um could not do that so she
chose to sue
so the justices heard the first
arguments in december of 71 why 10
months later were they back hearing the
case all over again
well there are apparently two reasons
why they decided in
in june of 1972 that they would not
decide the case then and would set it
down for re-argument
first of all in
the first argument the court only had
seven members
there were two vacancies harlan and
black had retired
and
the new
uh replacements who were rehnquist and
powell had not yet gone on the court so
there was some thought that if you're
going to make a major decision like this
striking down abortion laws like this it
would be better to do it with a nine
person court than the seven person court
but also we now know from
papers that have come out
in the 25 years since this case
that justice blackman was
trying to write a majority opinion after
that first argument
and was having trouble
convincing the court that he had a good
opinion there so
they also thought it might be good to
spend a little more time on it and
typically if the court can't
decide a case by june
what they do is schedule it for
re-argument the following fall and sort
of start all over
so what should people pay close
attention to as they hear the second
round of arguments
well you'll see that
the plaintiff's lawyer jane rose lawyer
sarah weddington
profited by
getting a second chance to argue this
case
she had had difficulty in the first
argument answering a pivotal question
which was where in the constitution do
you find a right to elect an abortion or
control your body
and
by the second argument she had worked
out a better answer and in fact
did a good job on that question how did
she answer it
she she said that the right is in the
14th amendment
the due process right not to deprive be
deprived of liberty and in fact that is
the basis on which blackman eventually
wrote his opinion
and the other thing to see in this
upcoming argument is that
the assistant attorney general who
argued the case the second time was a
different man um
from the one who argued at the first and
so therefore didn't have the benefit of
sort of this dry run
the prior year
and he stumbled he had some a lot of
difficulty answering the question about
is the fetus a person and why do you
think it's a person and what happens if
we conclude it's not a person
he sort of got all
messed up with that and the descending
opinions came from whom
the descending opinion from justice
white who was just going to dissent in
the first go-round and justice rehnquist
who's newly arrived on the court and
finally the political pressure at the
time that this case came before the
court what was it like in the country
well
i think that um you know the abortion
laws were in flux um
and
people you know a lot of people were
hoping the supreme court would strike
down
these very restrictive abortion laws
um but i don't think there was a lot of
optimism that the court would
some people in hindsight say maybe the
court shouldn't have maybe they should
have let it you know slowly get reformed
but
people were watching um and there was a
lot of interest
the decision came down january 22 1973
here is
the second round of oral arguments
taking place uh four months previously
in october 1972.
first in number 70 18
a row against wade
mrs weddington you may proceed whenever
you're ready
[Applause]
mr chief justice and may it please the
court
we are once again before this court to
ask relief against the continued
enforcement of the texas abortion
statute
and ask that you affirmed the ruling of
the three-judge court below which held
our statute unconstitutional for two
reasons
the first that it was vague and the
second
that it interfered with the ninth
amendment right of a woman to determine
whether or not she would continue or
terminate a pregnancy
[Applause]
as you will recall there are
three four
three plaintiffs and one intervenor
involved here
the first plaintiff was jane roe an
unmarried pregnant girl
who had sought an abortion in the state
of texas and was denied it because of
the texas abortion statute which
provides an abortionist lawful only for
the purpose of saving the life of the
woman
in the original action she was joined by
a married couple
john and mary doe
mrs doe had a medical condition
her doctor had recommended first that
she not get pregnant and second that she
not take the pill
after this cause was instituted and
after in fact the three judge court had
been granted
those three plaintiffs were joined by an
intervener dr halford who was at the
time he intervened under a pending state
criminal prosecution under the statute
he did not ask that his prosecution be
be
stopped by the court but rather joined
in the original request for a
declaratory judgment and injunctive
relief against future prosecutions
[Applause]
as a matter of fact he has not his
prosecution has not been continued
uh but the district attorney against
whom we file the suit has taken a
position that because there was no
injunction he is still free to institute
prosecutions
there is a letter from his office in the
appendix stating that he will continue
prosecutions and in fact there have been
a very limited number of prosecutions
instituted in the state of texas since
the three judge court entered its
declaratory judgment prosecutions of
doctors you're speaking prosecutions of
doctors yes sir
the problem that we face in texas is
that even though we were granted a
declaratory judgment ruling the law
unconstitutional and even though we've
been before this court once in the past
in texas women still are not able to
receive abortions from licensed doctors
because doctors still still fear that
they will be prosecuted under the
statute
if the declaratory judgment was any
relief at all it was an almost
meaningful relief because the women of
texas still must either travel to other
states if they are that sophisticated
and can afford it
or
they must resort to some other
less
um
some other very undesirable alternatives
you said meaningful you meant
meaningless didn't you
in fact we pointed out in our
supplemental brief filed here
that there have been something like 1600
texas women who have gone to new york
city alone for abortions in the first
nine months of 1971.
in addition i think the court would
recognize there are many other women
going to other parts of the country one
of the uh objections that our opponents
have raised is saying that this court is
moved because of course the woman is no
longer pregnant
it's been almost three years since we
instituted the original action
and yet we can certainly show that it is
a continuing problem to texas women
there still are unwanted pregnancies
there are still women who for various
reasons do not wish to continue the
pregnancy whether because of
personal health considerations whether
because of their family situation
whether because of financial situations
education working situations
some of the many things we discussed at
the last hearing
since the last hearing before this court
there have been a few cases decided that
we wanted to draw the court's attention
to and are covered in our supplemental
brief
in addition there is a supplemental
brief followed by an amicus party
harriet philpel on behalf of planned
parenthood of new york
that seeks to point out to the court at
pages six
and seven in subsequent pages some of
the changing medical statistics
available regarding the procedure of
abortion
for example that brief points out that
the overall maternal death rate
from legal abortion in new york dropped
to 3.7 per 100 000 abortions in the last
half of 1971 and that that in fact is
less than half the death death rate
associated with live delivery for women
that in fact the maternal morbidity
mortality rate has decreased by about
two-thirds to a record low in new york
in 1971.
that now in 1971 new york recorded the
lowest infant mortality rate
ever in that state
that during the first 18 months of 19
well from july 1st 1970 to december 31st
1971
out of wedlock pregnancies have dropped
by 14 percent
uh we now have other statistics coming
from california and other states that
show that not only has the overall birth
rate declined but the welfare birth rate
has also declined accordingly
[Applause]
as to the women this is their only forum
they are in a very unique situation for
several reasons
first because of the very nature of the
interest involved
their primary interest
being the interest associated
with the question of whether or not they
will be forced by the state
to continue an unwanted pregnancy
in our original uh brief
we alleged a number of constitutional
grounds the main one that we are relying
on before this court are the 5th the 9th
and the 14th amendments
there is a great body of president
certainly we cannot say that there is in
the constitution
so stated the right to an abortion
but neither is their stated the right to
travel or some of the other very basic
rights that this court have held are
under the united states constitution
the court has in the past for example
held that it is the right of the parents
and of the individual to determine
whether or not they will send their
child to private school whether or not
their children will be taught foreign
languages whether or not they will have
offspring the skinner case
whether
the right to determine for themselves
whom they will marry
the loving case and even in in body
versus connecticut the choice
saying that
that marriage itself is so important
that the state cannot interfere with
uh termination of a marriage just
because the woman is unable to pay the
cause
griswold of course is the primary case
holding that the state could not
interfere in the question of whether or
not a married couple would use birth
control and since then the course of
this court of course has held that the
individual has the right to determine
uh whether they are married or single
whether they will use birth control so
there there is a great body of cases
decided in the past by this court
in the areas of marriage sex
contraception procreation child bearing
and education of children which
says that there are certain things that
are so much a part of the individual
concern
that they should be left to the
determination of the individual
one of the cases decided
since our last argument december 13th
was the second connecticut case abel
versus markle
which
judge
[Applause]
excuse me nobody namely wrote the
opinion yes thank you
uh and judge lombard concurred
part of the lang in that case that
three-judge court held the connecticut
statute
a slightly revised statute for the
second time to be unconstitutional
and part of the language of that case
pointed out that no decision and
unquoting of the supreme court has ever
permitted anyone's constitutional right
to be directly a bridge to protect a
state interest which is subject to such
a variety of personal judgments
and certainly the amicus briefs stacked
before the court show the variety of
personal judgments
that come to bear on this particular
situation
to uphold such a statute the court said
would be to permit the state to impose
its view of the nature of a fetus upon
those who have the constitutional right
to base an important decision in their
personal lives upon a different view
again this is a very special type case
for the women because of the very nature
of the injury involved
it is an irreparable injury
once pregnancy has started certainly
this is not the kind of injury that can
be later adjudicated it is not the kind
of injury that can later be compensated
by some sort of monetary reward
these women who have now gone through
pregnancy and the women who continue to
be forced to go through pregnancy have
certainly gone through something that is
irreparable that can never be changed
for them
it is certainly great and it is
certainly immediate
uh there is no other forum available to
them
as we
talked last time
they are not subject in texas to any
kind of criminal prosecution whether the
woman performs self-abortion whether she
goes to a doctor finds someone who will
perform it on her she is guilty of no
crime whatsoever and yet the state tries
to allege that its purpose in this
statute was to protect the fetus if
that's true the fact the woman is guilty
of no crime
is not a reasonable kind of
[Applause]
it does not reasonably follow
this the women are not able to have any
kind of declaratory judgment in texas
because of our special declaratory
judgment statutes in our concurring
criminal and civil courts the two
different lines of cases that we have so
the federal court was the only court to
which the women had any kind of access
and it was to the federal courts they
came and it's the federal court
in my judgment
that should
determine this case
it's a very unique kind of harm
certainly that was done to them
even though there are many cases
some very recent from this court talking
about uh the problem
of when a state may interfere when their
or the federal judiciary may interfere
when there is a pending state criminal
prosecution
this case does come under the exceptions
in that there is great immediate
irreparable injury where there is no
other forum it is something that as far
as these women are concerned can never
be adjudicated in a criminal prosecution
much less in a single criminal
prosecution
[Applause]
it certainly is is an instance of a
situation that is capable of repetition
yet evading review
the judiciary simply does not move fast
enough for the case to be decided within
the period of gestation much less within
the period within which an abortion
would be
medically safe for these women
[Applause]
the state
has alleged and its only alleged
interest in this statute is the interest
in protecting the life of the unborn
however the state has not been able to
point to any authority of any nature
whatsoever that would demonstrate that
this statute was in fact adopted for
that purpose
we have some indication that other state
statutes were adopted for the purpose of
protecting the health of the woman we
have an 1880 case in texas
shortly after the 1854 statute was
adopted
that states that the woman is the victim
of the crime and is the only victim the
court talks about
we have all the contradictions
in the statute and the way
so many things that just don't make
sense if the statute was adopted for
that purpose for example why is the
woman guilty of no crime if the statute
was adopted for that purpose why is it
that the penalty for abortion is
determined by whether or not you have
the woman's consent
regardless of the purpose for which the
statute was originally enacted or the
purpose which keeps it on the books in
texas today
you would agree i suppose that one of
the
important factors that has to be
considered in this case is
what rights if any does the unborn fetus
have
that's correct there have been two cases
decided since the december 13th argument
that expressly whole that a fetus has no
constitutional rights
one ver being
burned versus new york and the other
being the mcgee women's hospital cases
in both situations a person sought to
bring that very question to the court
does a fetus in the in the one instance
burn was a challenge to the new york
revised statute the other was a
situation where a person sought to
prevent mcgee women's hospital from
allowing other abortions to be done in
that hospital and in both cases
it was held that the fetus had no
constitutional rights
several of the briefs before this court
would also argue that
this court in deciding the vowage case
which has allowed abortions to continue
in the district of columbia certainly
the court would not have made that kind
of decision if it felt there were any
ingrained
rights of the fetus within the
constitution
uh there have also there is also
critical to your case that the
fetus not to be a person under the uh
due process
it seems to me that it is critical first
that we prove this is a fundamental
interest on the behalf of the woman that
it is a constitutional right
okay and second that the state has no
compelling state interest
okay and the state is alleging a
compelling state interest but i'm just
asking you under the under the federal
constitution
is the fetus a person for the purpose of
the protection of the due process
all of the cases the prior history of
this statute the common law history
would indicate that it is not
the state has shown no
uh
well what if uh would you lose your case
if if the fetus was a person then you
would have a balancing of interest
you have anyway don't you excuse me you
have anyway don't you you're going to be
balancing the rights of the mother
against the rights of the fetus
it seems to me that you do not balance
constitutional rights of one person
against mere statutory rights of another
uh
you think
a state a state interest if it's only a
statutory interest or a constitutional
interest under the state law can never
outweigh a federal constitutional right
it would seem to me that so all the talk
of compelling state interests is uh
beside the point it can never be
compelling enough
if a state could show
that
the fetus was a person under the 14th
amendment
or under some other amendment are part
of the constitution
then you would have the situation of
trying
uh
you would have a state compelling
interest which in some instances can
outweigh a fundamental right
this is not the case in this particular
situation
do you make any distinction between the
first month and the ninth month of
gestation
our statute does not to you in your
position in this case
[Applause]
we are asking in this case that the
court declared the statute
unconstitutional the state having proved
no compelling interest at all
there are some states that now have
adopted time limits those have not yet
been challenged and perhaps that
question will be before this court
even those statutes though allow
exceptions
well for new york for example says an
abortion is lawful up to 24 weeks but
even after the 24 weeks it is still
lawful
where there's rape or incest
where the mother's mental or physical
health is involved in other words even
after that period it's not a
hard and fast cut off
then it's the weighing process
mr justice white was referring to is
that the legislature and in that
situation engaged in the weighing
process and
it seems to me that it has not yet been
determined whether the state
has the compelling interest to to uphold
even that kind of regulation but that's
really not before the court in this
particular case we have no time limit
uh
there is no indication in texas that any
would be applied in any future date you
know we just don't know that
but
mrs weddington you're uh
attacking the statute on two grounds are
you not both vagueness and the ninth
amendment you uh
place any greater weight on one argument
as against the other
our uh texas court of criminal appeals
in thompson versus state
case yes uh in november
on vegas
yes it uh that particular case held that
the texas statute was not bad citing
vowage
it's my opinion that that reliance was
misplaced
that in vowage this court had before at
the d.c statute which allowed abortion
for the purpose of saving the life or
the hell and this court adopted the
interpretation that health meant both
mental and physical health
and it seemed to me the court's language
in that case
uh talked a great deal about the fact
that the doctor's judgment goes to
saving the health of the woman that
that's the kind of judgment he is used
to making
in texas that's not the judgment he's
forced to make the judgment in texas is
is this necessary for the purpose of
preserving the life of the woman and the
language of that statute has never been
interpreted
that's not the kind of judgment that a
doctor is accustomed or perhaps even
able to make well i go back to my
question are you i still continue the
argument that the texas case is vague
uh so you're relying on both yes your
honor we are now you referred a little
bit to history and let me ask you a
question uh based in history
you're familiar with the hippocratic
oath i am
i think i
i may have missed it but i find no
reference to it in this uh
in your brief or in the voluminous
briefs that we're overwhelmed with here
do you have any comment about
hypocriticals
i think
two things could be said uh the first
would be that
that situations and understandings
change
uh in this case for example we have
before the court a medical amicus brief
that was joined by all the deans of the
public medical schools in texas
it was joined by numerous other
professors of medicine it was joined by
the american college of obstetricians
and gynecologists
there are other briefs on the other side
joined by equally outstanding physicians
tell me why you didn't discuss the
hypocritical okay
i i guess it was uh
okay
in part because uh the hippocratic oath
we discussed basically the
constitutional protection we felt the
woman to have
the hippocratic oath does not pertain to
that
second we discussed the fact that the
state had not established a compelling
state interest the hippocratic ocean
would not really pertain to that
and then we discussed the vagueness
jurisdiction it seemed to us that that
that
that the fact that
the medical profession
at one time had adopted the hippocratic
oath does not
weigh upon the fundamental
constitutional rights involved
it is a guide for physicians but the
outstanding organizations of the medical
profession have in fact adopted a
position that says the doctor and the
patient should be able to make the
decision for themselves in this kind of
situation
of course it's the only definitive
statement of ethics in the medical
profession i i take it from what you
just said that
you're you didn't even footnote it
because it's old that's about really
what you're saying
well
i guess you
it is old and and not that it's out of
date but that it it seemed to us that it
was not pertinent to the argument we
were making
let me ask another question then
last june 29
this court decided the
capital punishment cases yes sir
do you feel that there is any
inconsistency in the court's decision in
those cases
outline the death penalty with respect
to
convicted murderers and rapists
[Applause]
at one end of lifespan
and your position
in
this case
at the other end of lifespan
i think
had there been established that the
fetus was a person under the 14th
amendment or under constitutional
protection then there might be
a differentiation
in this case
there has never been established that
the fetus is a person or that it's
entitled to the 14th amendment rights or
the protection of the constitution
it would be inconsistent to decide that
after birth various classifications of
persons would be subject to the death
penalty or not
but here we have a person
the woman entitled to fundamental
constitutional rights as opposed
to the fetus prior to birth
where there is no establishment of any
kind of federal constitutional rights
well do i get from this then that your
case depends primarily on the
proposition that the fetus has no
constitutional rights
it depends on saying that the woman has
a fundamental constitutional right and
that the state has not proved any
compelling interest for regulation in
the area
even even if the court at some point
determined the fetus to be
entitled to constitutional protection
you would still get back into the
weighing of one life against another
[Applause]
and that's what that's what's involved
in this case
weighing one life against another know
your honor i said that would be what
would be involved if
the facts were different and the state
could prove that there was a person for
the constitutional right well if
if it were established that an unborn
fetus as a person within the protection
of the 14th amendment you would have
almost an impossible case here which i
would have a very difficult certainly
would because you'd have the same kind
of thing you'd have to say that
this would be the equivalent after a
child was born if
the mother thought it bothered her
health having a child around she would
uh she could have it killed
isn't that correct
could texas constitutionally did you
want to respond further to justice
stewart
did you want to respond further to it
could texas constitutionally in your
view
uh
declare that by statute that uh
fetus is a person for all constitutional
purposes after the
third month of gestation
i do not believe that the state
legislature can determine the meaning of
the federal constitution
it is up to this court to make that
determination
the state could obviously adopt that
kind of statute and then the question
would have to be adjudicated as to
whether for all purposes that statute is
constitutional we are not alleging that
there cannot be some kind of protection
uh for example the property rights which
again are contingent on being upon being
born alive but can be retroactive to the
period prior to birth but in this
particular situation we are alleging uh
that
that this statute is unconstitutional
they have been recognized in the period
before birth for purposes of injury
claims you put that i take it in the
property texas that is only when they
are born alive and the fact that there
is a wrong you know the wrongful uh
conduct of another is not the same as in
this situation as to property rights for
example there there are even property
rights that relate back to prior to
conception children that are not yet
conceived can later
inherit but that doesn't that did not
prevent this court and griswold from
holding people had the right to birth
control
mr flowers
mr chief justice and may it please the
court
[Applause]
the lower court
in dallas
held
the
texas abortion law unconstitutional
primarily on the two grounds that has
just been discussed
on the vagueness question
and
the
rights of the mother under the ninth
amendment
the thrust of the
whole argument of the state of texas
is
against the rights of the mother under
the ninth amendment
that it certainly is a balancing effect
there must be or
on the other side of the coin texas has
no state
[Applause]
it is impossible for me to trace
within my a lot of allocated time
uh
the development of the fetus
from the date of conception
to the date of its birth but it is the
position of the state of texas
that upon conception we have a human
being
a person within the concept of the
constitution of the united states and
that of texas also now how should we how
should that question be decided is it a
legal question a constitutional question
a medical question a philosophical
question a religious question or what is
it your honor we we feel that it could
be best decided by a legislature in view
of the fact that they can bring before
it the medical testimony the actual
people who do the research
but we do
basically a medical question uh
from a constitutional standpoint no sir
i think it's fairly squarely before this
court
uh we don't envy the
uh the court for having to make this
decision do you know of any case
anywhere that's held at an unborn fetus
as a person within the meaning of the
14th amendment no sir we can only go
back to what the framers of our
constitution had in mind well these
weren't the framers who wrote the 14th
amendment that came along no sure uh i
understand but the fifth amendment uh
under the fifth amendment no one shall
be deprived of a right to life liberty
and property without the due process
lawful yes but then the fourteenth
amendment defines person and it defines
person as somebody who's born doesn't it
i'm not sure about how
[Applause]
any person born
or naturalized in the united states
[Applause]
doesn't i suppose that's not a
definition of a person but
that's a definition of a citizen your
honor it's our position that uh the
definition of a person is so basic
it's so fundamental
that it is the framers of the
constitution uh had
not even
set out to define
we can only go to what the teachings
at the time of the constitution was
framed
[Applause]
we have
numerous
[Applause]
listings in the brief by
uh mr joe witherspoon professor
university of texas
that tries to trace back what was in
their mind when they had this person
concept when they drew up the
constitution
he quoted
blackstone in 1765
and he observed in his commentaries
that life
this right is inherent
by nature in every individual and exists
even before the child is born
i submit to you that
the declaration of independence
we hold when you quote blackstone is it
not true that in blackstone's time
abortion was not a felony
that that's true uh your honor but what
my point there was to
see the thinking of the framers of the
constitution from the people they learn
from
and the general attitude of the time
well i i think i'm just wondering if
there's a basic inconsistency there
and
let me go back to something else that
you said it is it not true or is it true
that the medical profession itself is
not in agreement as to when life begins
i think that's true sir
uh but
from a layman's standpoint medically
speaking we would say that at the moment
of conception from the chromosomes
every potential
that anybody in this room has is pressed
from the moment of conception then
you're speaking of potential of life yes
sir with which everyone can agree
perhaps on the seventh day i think that
the heart in some form starts beating
on the 20th day uh
practically all the facilities are there
that you and i have your honor
uh
i think if you're uh you're correct that
the uh that the
fetus is a person
[Applause]
uh
then i don't suppose uh you would have a
the state would have great trouble
permitting an abortion
yes sir and in any circumstance it would
yes to save the life of the mother or
her health or anything else
well
there would be the balancing of the two
lies and i think that uh
what would you choose would you choose
to kill the innocent one or what
well in this in our statute the state
did choose that way your honor
well in the protection of the mother
well could the state of texas say that
if
it's for the benefit of the health of
the wife they can kill the husband
i'm sorry i didn't understand it but
could texas say if it comes to situation
for the benefit of the help of the wife
that the husband has to die could they
kill him
i wouldn't think so sir
[Applause]
is there any statute in texas that
prohibits a
doctor from performing any operation
other than an abortion i don't i don't
think so sir and there is uh
another thrust of our argument
if
we declare as the apple at least in this
case
have asked this court declare that an
embryo or a fetus is a mass of
protoplasm
similar to a tumor then of course the
state has no compelling interest
whatsoever
there is no the only operation that a
doctor
can possibly commit that will bring on a
criminal penalty is an abortion yes why
as far as well why don't you limit some
other operations
because this is the uh
only type of operation that would take
another human life well a brain
operation could
well there again that that would be uh
i think that in in every feat that a
doctor performs
that he is constantly making this
judgment well if a doctor performs the
brain operation and does it improperly
he could be guilty of manslaughter
couldn't he
i would think so if he was like why
couldn't you charge him with
manslaughter if he commits an abortion
in effect your honor we did
in uh
the statute 1195
that has been very carefully avoided all
throughout these proceedings is not
attacked as unconstitutional for some
reason
uh
if you permit me to visit initiative
no sir uh you asked the question about
whether we had uh
made manslaughter uh
abortion manslaughter
uh
maybe the reason is
is why i have two sketches
well this was in context with uh
this is 1195 they are attacking
1191-1196
but omitted uh 1195
here's what 1195 say provides
whoever shall during the
par
parturation of the mother destroy the
vitality or life in a child in a state
of being born before actual birth and
before actual birth
which child would have otherwise been
born alive which
shall be confined to the penitentiary
for life
or not less than five years
what does this touch it mean
sir what does it mean
uh i would think that uh
it is an offense to kill a child in the
process of childbirth yes sir it would
be uh immediately before child birth or
right in the proximity of the child
being born which is not an abortion
which is not would not be an abortion
yes your correction it would be homicide
[Applause]
gentlemen we feel that the concept of
a fetus
being
in the within the concept
of a person
within the framework of the united
states constitution and the texas
constitution
is is an extremely fundamental thing of
course if you're right about that
you can sit down you you've won your
case your honor
matt accept him so far as maybe the
texas abortion law presently goes too
far and allowing abortion yes sir that's
exactly right
uh we feel that that this is the only
question really that this court has to
answer
we have uh i think the case is over for
you
if if
the fetus or the embryo was not a person
is that it yeah sure i would say so
you mean uh you mean the state has no uh
interest that it of its own that it can
assert uh and uh oh we have other
interests your honor
uh
preventing uh
uh promiscuity say
maybe
your legislature apparently uh
or you're asserting that the state that
your state law uh
wants to protect the uh life of the
fetus yes sir
and under state law
uh
uh there is some rights given there are
some rights given to the fetus yeah sure
and you are asserting those rights
against the uh right of the mother
balancing against the ninth amendment
right
but that's only aside from whether or
not the penis is a person under the
federal constitution
you can still assert those rights
whether the fetus is a person or not
yeah sure
[Applause]
does texas have uh
traditional statutes on mutilation
maybe the criminal act yes so that there
are other uh survival procedures which
could be criminal that's right the man
walked into a doctor's office and said i
want you to cut off my right
arm
uh because he's offended me castration
yes sir i had forgotten about those
you're on doctors apply to doctors
i would assume so sir anyone you have
any case that says so no sir
[Applause]
i would say that there would have to be
a culpability of mine
proven there in most criminal cases
[Applause]
john i'd like to call the attention of
the court of
that the
unborn child
uh
if
that this court has not been blind
to the rights of the unborn child in the
past
in
the memorial
case versus anderson a new jersey
supreme court
case
the court
this was a case where the pregnant woman
had refused on religious grounds to undo
a blood transfusion
and in order to save the child
[Applause]
the court held that
the right of the child to live and
to be born
was
paramount over
this pregnant woman's right of religion
i think that here is exactly what we're
facing in this case is the life of this
unborn fetus
paramount over the
woman's right to determine whether or
not
she shall bear a child
in blickman versus cosgrove it's a new
jersey supreme court court case
it's a tart action instituted against
the doctor as a result of his failure
to warn
the mother that she was suffering from
german measles in order that
she could terminate her pregnancy
the court
recognized
the life of the embryo
and stated that it would have been
easier for the mother and less expensive
for the father
this alleged detriment cannot stand
against the preciousness of one single
life
in jones versus state
excuse me jones versus jones a new york
supreme court
held that the unborn child was a patient
of the mother's obstetrician as well as
the mother herself
[Applause]
in jackson versus indiana this court
cellistly guarded the rights of a
[ __ ] child
now if we're going to extend the right
of a child who has reached its potential
it cannot go on and grow it cannot go on
and grow mentally and achieve
then how much more right should we
afford to
a child who is
has all of the potential
of achieving
[Applause]
the prince versus
commonwealth massachusetts case this
course was faced with the contention
that
state statute uh recruited precluding
uh labor by a child intended years and
distributed in religious tracts
was protected that the child's right
to grow up
and to become educated and fully
developed
was paramount to these parents
religious beliefs
[Applause]
this court has been diligent in
protecting the rights of the minorities
and gentlemen we say that this is a
minority a silent minority the true
silent minority
who is speaking for these children
where is the council
for
these unborn children whose life is
being taken
where is the safeguard of the right to
trial by jury
[Applause]
are we to place this power in the hands
of a mother and a doctor
all of the constitutional rights
if this person has the person concept
what would keep
a legislature
under this grounds from deciding who
else
might or might not be a human being or
might not be a person
well generally speaking i think you've
agreed that up until now the test has
been whether or not somebody's been born
and that's the word used in the 14th
amendment yeah sure that's what would
keep the legislature i suppose from
classifying people who've been born as
not persons would your honor it seems to
me that the physical act of being born
i'm not playing it down i
i know it's a
very momentous incident
but what changes
is it a non-human
and changing by the act of birth into a
human well that's been the theory up
until now
well in other words it has been the
theory that that we have deriving from
non-human material a human being
after conception
with your honor uh i said that's the
reason i asked you at the beginning what
uh
within what
framework should this question be
decided should it be a theological one
or a philosophical one or a medical one
or
are we confined here to dealing with uh
i think your honor that the quartisal
meaning of it
i wish i could answer that i believe
that the court must take these uh the
medical research
and apply it to our constitution the
best they can
i uh
said i'm without envy of
the burden that the court has
i think that
possibly we have an opportunity to make
one of the worst mistakes here that
we've ever made
but there's no medical testimony that
backs up your statement it goes from
inception is there
only that uh medical
sorry in this case you're talking about
no is there any medical testimony of any
kind that says that
a fetus is a person at the time of
inception
your honor i uh
would
like to call
the court's attention
in answering that question
uh what i
feel to believe uh
one of the better culminations
of
the medical research
and that was senior judges
campbell's dissenting opinion in the doe
versus scott which is very similar to
the case we have before
he goes in chronological order uh what
the medical research has determined
from
the chromosome structure at the time of
in conception what the potential is
down through each day of life
until it's born
i understood you to say the state of
texas says it extends
from the date of inception until the
child is born the date of conception
till the day of yeshua and that's it
now you're not quoting a judge i want
you to give me a medical
recognizable medical
writing of any kind that says that at
the time of conception
that if the fetus
is a person
i
do not believe that i could give that to
you without researching through the
briefs that have been filed in this case
your honor
i'm not sure that i can give it to you
did judge campbell rely on medical
authorities in that statement you're
summarizing yes sir he did
this case uh was
uh the court held there that that really
the problem could be answered
on an extension of the uh griswold case
and uh here's what my descending judge
had to say about that which we adopt
your honor
said uh
inciting griswold the majority concludes
we cannot distinguish the interest
asserted by the plaintiffs in this case
from those asserted in griswold
in other words in their views there is
no distinction that can be made between
prohibiting the use of contraceptives
and prohibiting the destruction of fetal
life
which as explained above may reasonably
be construed
to be a human life
i find this assertion incredible
contraceptive prevents creation of new
life
abortion destroys existing life
abortion uh contraceptives and abortion
are as distinguishable
as thoughts and dreams are
distinguishable from a reality
now
well where the medical authorities you
told mr justice wren because he cited
are they there yes sir he lists them day
by day uh uh just prior to this time sir
but it's quite lengthy
where is that you're reading from it's
uh
uh 321 federal supplement
on page
394. sir
and i or 392 it begins your honor and i
refer you to his
uh uh
medical uh condensation because i read
most of
uh most of the comments that he has to
make through
through the
throughout
these many many briefs
that we have had submitted in this case
in other cases
[Applause]
for instance he starts off uh
we did
see as the illinois legislature would
have before us the following undisputed
facts relating to fetal life
seven weeks after conception the
fertilized egg develops into a
well-proportioned small-scale baby and
then goes from there on
now i i know he doesn't address himself
your honor to the moment of conception i
didn't think so uh uh you're entirely
right there and
but i
find
no way that i know
that
any court or any legislature or any
doctor anywhere can say that here is the
dividing line
here is not a life and here is a life
after conception
[Applause]
perhaps it would be
better left to our legislators
there they have the facilities to have
some type of medical history
brought before
and the
opinion of the people who are being
governed by this
well if you're right that an unborn
fetus is a person
then you can't leave it to the
legislature to play fast and loose with
that
dealing with that person in other words
uh if you're correct in your basic
submission that an unborn fetus is a
person then
abortion laws such as that uh
which new york has is grossly
unconstitutional isn't it that's right
allowing the allowing the killing of
people yes of persons you're under the
massachusetts i might point out leave
this up to the legislature there's a
constitutional problem isn't it
well if there would be any exceptions uh
within the basic constitutional question
initially is whether or not an unborn
fetus is a person isn't it and entitled
to the constitutional thing that's
critical to this case yes it is
and we feel that uh the
treatment that the courts have given
unborn children in dissent distribution
property rights tort laws
have all pointed out that they have
in the past have
given credits to this
concept
mr flower
doesn't the fact that so many of the
state abortion statutes
do provide for exceptional situations in
which abortion may be performed and
presumably these date back a great
number of years
uh following mr justice stewart's
comment suggests that the absolute
proposition that a
fetus from the time of conception is a
person it just
is at least against the weight of
historical legal approach to the
question
yes sir i would
think possibly that that would indicate
that uh
however your honor
in this whole
field of abortion here
we
have uh
on the one hand
uh
uh great clamoring for this
liberalization of it
perhaps this is good population
explosion we have at least so many
uh
things that are arriving on the scene in
the past few years
that
might have some effect on
producing this type of legislature
rather than
facing the facts squarely
i don't think anyone has faced the fact
in making a decision whether this is
a life
in a personal concept
[Applause]
thank you mr flowers one was the first
abortion statute adopted in your state
your honor in 1854
prior to 1854 what was the situation in
texas i i don't think it was in a stance
your honor
so on your i think it was silent the
state was silent
so on your theory destruction of
a person
in the form of a fetus
was legal
yes sir uh
well at least the
legislature hadn't spoken on your honor
well it was legal yeah sure
flowers did texas have an abortion
statute on the books at the time
at least in the eyes of the north and
was readmitted to the union after the
civil war no i'm sure the state was uh
admitted to the union in 1845 your honor
well at the time that it was uh
past muster with uh
when it was a republic well
my my historical impression is that
following the civil war congress uh
went through the procedure at any rate
of readmitting the states which had
seceded and
passing on
their constitutional provisions and that
sort of thing did texas have an abortion
statute at that time yes sir
it was passed in 1854
you know as a matter of
historical fact
when most of these abortion statutes
came on the
books i think it was uh
most of them were in the
mid-1800s
in fact the latter half of the 19th
century
you know why they all came on at that
time
no sure
i
i
surely don't
sure the materials indicate that
generally speaking they are enacted to
protect the health and lives of pregnant
women
because of the danger of operative
procedures generally in that ira
environment
i'm sure that was a great factor your
honor
well isn't it historically uh pretty
well accepted as a fact that
in the early period of the history of
this country there was general reliance
upon religious discipline to
preclude this
kind of
activity abortions and
when that didn't seem to
cover it then the states began to enact
statutes yes sir has had been done in
england also uh in the uh
exploration and the uh this uh indian
days if you wish the frontier days
uh i don't imagine that too many uh
abortions were intentional and abortions
were created in this
these united states
people was of such a necessity to
develop
the united states
thank you
this is uh weddington you have four
minutes left thank you your honor
i think mr flowers well made the point
when he said that no one can say here is
the dividing line here is where life
begins here is
life is here and life is not over here
in a situation where no one can prove
where life begins where no one can show
that the constitution was adopted that
it was meant to protect fetal life in
those situations where it has shown that
that kind of decision is so
fundamentally a part of individual life
of the family of such fundamental impact
on the person
your argument is that
a state may not protect the life
at this time my point is that this
particular statute is unconstitutional
[Applause]
at this time there is no indication to
show that the constitution would give
any protection prior to birth
that is not before the court and that is
the question i don't know
whether it is or it isn't
if the statute you're claiming statutes
that's correct now uh is that possible
the statute
before you can declare the statute
void on its face
that you have to say that
it's void
no matter when
in the pregnancy and the abortion takes
place
it seems to me in this situation the
court is excuse me i i must would you
ask the question again
well is the statute void but does that
just be void on his face if the state
could revamp abortions at any time uh
after six months
i mean if the state in fact did that
let's assume that it's constitutional
for the state
to prevent abortions after six months
it would still be void on its face in
this situation because it is overly
broad it it interferes in a
at a time when the state has free speech
the statute might be perfectly valid uh
[Applause]
my argument would first be that it's
void on its face and second if the court
finds it's not void on its face that it
certainly is void because it infringes
upon the fundamental right at a time
when the state can show no compelling
interest early in pregnancy what did
this court say about
voidness in the vowage case
what did we say there there you said the
particular dc statute was not void for
vagueness it's a different statute there
was an interpretation of the meaning of
the statute and the court there said the
doctor could work within that context
and could tell what the statute meant
well then the only what isn't the only
difference between the texas statute and
the d.c statute that the
texas statute does not have the health
factor you know that's correct which
makes it much more difficult for the
doctor to tell when it is comfortable
unless the court was prepared to
overrule it
modified the texas statute would be
valid if it was construed to
include uh abortions for the protection
of health treating life as broad enough
to mental and physical
but then the question is raised as to
the right of privacy which was not
before the court in the vowage case and
is before the court in this particular
situation
uh as to the hippocratic oath it seems
to me that that oath was adopted at a
time when abortion was extremely
dangerous
to the health of the woman
and second that the oath uh is to
protect life and here the question is
what does life mean in this particular
context
uh it's the sort of same vagueness that
seems to me that you're well okay life
there could be slightly different
because the constitutional implications
here it seems to me either
went directly and specifically to a body
of
procedure to providing whatever is
however likely that's correct
as to mutilation uh there it seems to me
that the purpose of those statutes was
to prevent the citizen from becoming a
dependent or ward of the state and also
to ensure that its citizens would be
available for service in the military
in this particular instance
the rationale works just the opposite
here a woman because of her pregnancy is
often not a productive member of society
she cannot work she cannot hold a job
she's not eligible for welfare she
cannot get unemployment compensation and
furthermore in fact the pregnancy may
produce a child who will become a ward
of the state
we do not object to the cases
such as the transfusion case
where there is a decision already made
by the woman that she desires to carry
the pregnancy to term and when that
decision is made that the child should
be given every opportunity to come into
life a healthy
person
we do not believe that that necessitates
the conclusion that therefore under the
constitution
prior to birth a person under the 14th
amendment would exist there
this case this court is faced with a
situation where there have been 14
three-judge courts that have ruled on
the constitutionality of abortion
statutes nine courts have favored the
woman five have gone against her 25
judges have favored the woman 17 have
gone against her nine circuit judges
have favored the woman five have gone
against her 16 district court judges
have favored the woman 10 have gone
against her
no one is more keenly aware of the
gravity of the issues or the moral
implications of this case but it is a
case that must be decided on the
constitution
we do not disagree that there is a
progression of fetal development it is
the conclusion to be drawn from that
upon which we disagree
we are not here to advocate abortion we
do not ask this court to rule that
abortion is good or desirable in any
particular situation
we are here to advocate that the
decision as to whether or not a
particular woman will continue to carry
or will terminate a pregnancy is a
decision that should be made by that
individual that in fact she has a
constitutional right to make that
decision for herself and that the state
has shown no interest in interfering
with that decision
our supplemental brief on page 14 points
out that the brief of the opposition
can't quite decide when life does begin
at one point they suggest it's when
there's implantation a few pages later
they suggest it's with conception but
any doctor
may refuse her
certainly your honor he may he may
refuse any kind of medical procedure
whatsoever
[Applause]
here it's the question of whether or not
the state by the statute will force the
woman to continue
the woman should be given that freedom
just as the doctor has the freedom to
decide what procedures he will carry out
and what he will refuse to his patients
i i take it from your recent remarks
that
you are urging upon us abortion on
demand of the woman alone
not in conjunction with her physician
i am urging that in this particular
context this statute is unconstitutional
that in the baird versus eisenstadt case
this court said if the right of privacy
is to mean anything it is the right of
the individual whether married or single
to make determinations for themselves it
seems to me that you cannot say this is
a woman of this particular doctor and
this particular woman it is
it is it seems to me
uh well doesn't it follow from that then
that a woman can come into a doctor's
office and say i want an abortion and he
can say i'm sorry i don't perform them
and then what does she do she goes
elsewhere
if she so chooses if she stays with that
you know it's
that's an impossible question
uh certainly she i don't think the state
could say the first doctor a woman goes
to she'll make that determination and
she cannot go elsewhere
your time is up now mrs weddington thank
you mrs weddington thank you mr flowers
the case is submitted
susan lowe block of georgetown
university law center the second round
of oral arguments taking place in
october 1972 the decision coming down
just a couple of months later
what's your view of the opinion and what
came from this case
well the opinion was written by justice
brackman
and he
made two important conclusions one he
concluded for the court it was a seven
to two decision so he had um
six other justices with him
um he concluded first that a fetus was
not a person under the 14th amendment
and he concluded that under the 14th
amendment which says you cannot be
deprived of
life liberty or property without due
process that the liberty part of that
included the right of a woman to control
what happens with her body
and because
he found that liberty clause protecting
a right to control your body the state
had to have a very strong compelling
justification for
insisting that a woman remain pregnant
against her will
and
he
conclude he then analyzed the pregnancy
in terms of three trimesters
and found different state justifications
for each trimester what was the reaction
in the rest of the country what he he
said that uh in the first trimester you
can't
the state can't really regulate abortion
um in the second trimester
it can but only for the health of the
mother and then the last trimester the
state could come in and try and protect
the potential life of the fetus
um the reaction was uh quite
overwhelming it so happened i think that
it so happened on the day that the
opinion was announced lbj died so the
headlines were
a bit
taken up by that but
the reaction um was extreme by
especially the conservative and the
religious groups
um blackman received a lot of hate mail
really for the you know i think he still
gets it to this day
um brennan as a catholic received a lot
of hate mail but
uh in general the court was just deluged
by angry letters gruesome photographs um
picketing
it was a
it's it's a very controversial decision
and
it's still to this day on january 22nd
the court gets picketed every year any
surprises though from
either round of oral arguments
um
i don't think there were any real
surprises um
i don't know you never can tell too much
from moral argument in terms of which
way the court is leaning they always ask
the hardest questions that they can of
both sides
so i don't think that there were
too many surprises i think
sarah weddington did better the second
time
practice does help um
but um
the uh the reaction to the case was what
was so extreme i remember a christmas
card that
thurgood marshall
justice brennan and justice blackmon got
saying hope this is your last christmas
so it was quite and justice blackman had
death threats so it was
this was a very
controversial decision and finally two
dissenting views there were two
descending views justice white
dissented and justice rehnquist who is
new to the court dissented
susan loblock of georgetown university
thank you you're welcome thank you
[Music]